bom dia a todos
na tv que se tornou vice
deixem que vos apresento um pequeno
inseto é a ciência que é nossa no iraque
ao topo da lista quando tinha 12 anos
em casa os pais das crianças rose da
natureza eu passava longas horas com um
curioso porque estava a ver a sua vida
sem ganhar
aconteceu até porque o meu amigo próximo
da cada um
mesmo em mim hospital américa disso a
velha e como tal da próxima vez que o
aplicado imediatamente o hospital marcou
e eu só voltaria a ser picado por
abelhas 30 anos mais tarde quando foi
modificar estas abelhas questão que foi
para uma pea e pedagógico com o
movimento de parentes em transição
eu pertenço acre onde já formamos mais
tanques em novos apicultores ia e piada
que o max ou apiário para buscar
imediatamente o apicultor devia ter
andado a brincar com meios neste mercado
nunca mais agressiva
é complicado
não tive reação alérgica quer então a
foi foi uma nova foi com suas velhas a
um ritual necessário uma nova uma nova
atividade como autor
a imagem é é um enxame altura altura
mais crítica porque elas têm que
reservar ia e por outro lado um enxame
de estimação novas todos os dias e elas
têm que ser alimentado
a meta é aumentar só conseguem ser como
a que acontece às vezes é isso quando
nós movimentamos a pior
o ano passado foi o frio foi um dos que
estiveram nas unhas e alguns serão mais
50 por cento isto é apenas um exemplo do
que se passa um pouco por cima fora
todos nós já vimos na televisão em
jornais que era e não é só isso
há as velhas tal como nós humanos
precisam ter uma alimentação variada e
saudável e com o lançamento da
agricultura industrial é cada vez elas
conseguem ter essa deve ser a da flor do
tipo para se alimentar e também muito
ligado à área da agricultura
este é um sintoma do um vírus que
transmite muitas outras atividades a
serem transportadas de avião neste
momento encontramos a falar da austrália
e estados unidos
qualquer coisa como cozinhas junto
estamos num momento em que temos como
fazer qualquer coisa um pouco no tempo
esta é uma velha em como tirar nossas
regras ea e participam numa das mãos do
suíço que o planeta terra já nessa
altura a floresta era dominada por festa
e por plantas térmicas pinheiro a são
utilizadas por venda
as plantas angiospermas as plantas
superiores das plantas com flor estão
espalhadas pelo planeta
era uma pena um ensaio da natureza e ao
recrutar 17 com esta velha está fazendo
o trabalho da polícia são elas não
estavam já só imitar os aumentos a não
usar também este incêndio e foi uma
parceria de sucesso
tantas plantas angiospermas com mais
velhas
esta parceria que hoje não podemos
passar sem nenhuma e nós temos aqui um
projeto próprio que o projeto dá nenhum
com o que temos aqui é boa nova não
temos na terra realmente elas conseguem
uma coisa é que temos mais temos mais a
fazer
e agora na volta não passa para
organizar também colocou também gostou
também é preciso que sejam utilizadas 7
para termos o nosso também não passam
sem se utilizar a faz ficar não façam
mau tom é um caso de agressão mas eu
consegui ficar aqui também vai fazer
companhia a companhia já temos aqui o
nome do craque velho tá tudo que queria
ficar batata alface e agrião uma idéia
dependendo da velha que não podemos
fazer para ajudar nesta difícil
elas têm grandes culpados de algumas das
coisas que nós queremos fazer é criar
hortas biológicas versa também utilizar
as plantas nas 89 das frutas vamos ter
um orçamento anos que é um princípio de
uma horta biológica comprar alimentos
agricultura biológica ainda que quanto
mais fácil nós tivermos ocupados por
a agricultura biológica - passo vamos
ter os projetos parceiros é isto é um
amigo francisco foi eu plantou um pra
espertas começou a fazer um caminho da
salvada tecnológico da flores e estamos
a convidar 2007 visitar eu descobrir que
no jardim numa venda do chamado anel é
uma mostra dos insetos visita vai
contribuir com a natureza e com meus
pagam e não só pela sua presença e
poderemos também são junto da autarquia
seria uma grande coisa se deixassem de
fazer isso
plantar também existe no porto é é uma
coisa muito muito muito em santos fazer
em portugal
quando o exemplo vem de cima
realmente os resultados podem ser
fantástico quando cruzava trouxe para
casa
ward mas a comitiva presidencial
eu não posso deixar de acreditar que a
quantidade de e estados unidos que pode
ser parte da solução que pode ser um
novo autor
espero que você vê
talvez por ser algo e talvez porque tem
que fazer alguma coisa e eu vejo muitas
pessoas querem trabalhar com cultura -
cultura mais cultura mais natural mais
sustentável mais próximo da natureza
um exemplo pode ser feito aqui que
estamos a fazer é deixar as ovelhas
fazer o seu próprio fado como elas fazem
amizade e não estamos a tentar controlar
os maneira muito muito interessante
cultura seria a maneira mais fácil e
mais rápida
criamos cultura
seria muito bom se pudéssemos fazer
efeito
por exemplo em londres em paris e nova
york em toronto e vancouver em viana
onde a cultura não só é é permitida
neste momento atingiu popularidade
fantásticas
só para ter uma idéia
por isso tornou-se a capital da cultura
urbana
há pessoas que visitam paris já qualquer
idéia de que não posso ir a paris em
comprar mel e o preço do mel vocês não
haver lei criou se uma nova economia à
volta desta possibilidade foi criada das
pessoas terem um mês na cidade de 240
euros o quilo ou 30 euros por um
frasquinho 125 ano para o começo difícil
mas já imaginou
desta maneira o organismo das pessoas
que visitam portugal portuguesa cultura
é natural limpa e é este tentava
e nós estamos num filme fantástico tão
triste que nós precisamos na verdade o
futuro e agora só tenho uma coisa é tal
renda piscicultores que que eu assinei
já está já existe a começar a criar soya
e este a apresentação que eu fiz agora
teve a colaboração mais as pessoas
diferentes com sugestões com imagens e
do próximo mês com o primeiro faça no
culto 87 tipo de agricultura que o fato
foi um prazer estar aqui com vocês muito
obrigado por você